DAN GALPIN: Hello.
I'm Dan Galpin for
"The Developer Show."
This is your update about
the coolest developer news
from Google in the last week.
The sixth international
Conference
on Learning Representations
is in Canada this week.
It's a conference
focused on how we
can learn meaningful and
useful representations of data
for machine learning.
We've got over 130
researchers attending,
but don't worry if
you can't make it.
You can learn more about the
research we're presenting
with the links on this post.
You can now include variables
in the documentation
section of your
alerting policies
for Google Stackdriver.
The contents of
this field are also
now included in Slack
and Webhook notifications
in addition to email.
Take a look at the post for a
screenshot and example markup.
To make it easier to connect to
Google Cloud Platform services
from either a GCP-hosted or
an on-prem Kubernetes cluster,
we are releasing Kubernetes
Service Catalog, a collection
of services available to
Kubernetes running on GCP
and the Google Cloud
Platform Service
Broker, a hosted
service that connects
to a variety of GCP services.
A screenshot and link to
the docs are on the post.
We recently announced several
cloud database improvements,
including commit timestamps
for Cloud Spanner,
availability of Cloud
Bigtable replication in beta,
and availability of Cloud
Memorystore for Redis in beta.
More details are on the post.
Partner Interconnect provides
high bandwidth connectivity
to the nearest Google
Cloud Platform region
through our many partners.
Like Dedicated Interconnect,
Partner Interconnect
offers private
connectivity to GCP
to organizations that
don't require the full 10
gigabits per second of
a dedicated circuit.
It also allows organizations
whose data centers are
geographically distant
from a Google Cloud region
or point of presence to connect
to GCP using our partners'
connections.
You can learn more on the post.
The Associate Cloud Engineer
Certification beta exam
is now open for registration.
This certification
identifies you
as someone who has the
foundational skills
necessary to use Google Cloud
console to deploy applications,
monitor operations, and
manage enterprise solutions.
A link to register
is on the post.
Next week is Google I/O, and
the "Developer Show" team
will be on site broadcasting
live from the Shoreline
Amphitheater.
Tune in for the
pre-show performance,
the keynotes, special
guest interviews,
play time in the
sandbox, summaries
of our favorite sessions,
and so much more.
We'll skip the TL;DR next week,
and be back the week after with
highlights from I/O.
Please remember to like,
subscribe, and share.
I'm Dan Galpin for
"The Developer Show."
Thanks for watching.
We'll see you at Google I/O.
All right.
SPEAKER 1: Feeling better now?
DAN GALPIN: Yeah,
feeling better.
SPEAKER 1: OK.